ils sont heureux les collégiens d'amiral
Bouvet à Saint-Benoît ces jeunes ont en
effet de quoi être fiers puisqu'ils ont
raflé pas moins de deux récompenses lors
des 6e rencontres et correspondables de
bras pas non ils ont été couronnés par
un premier prix dans la catégorie
collège qui s'accompagne du Trophée de
ses rencontres et correspondables l'idée
par est simple mais a su fait desrer
faire naître de vraies passions au sein
du collège allons donc parcourir le
sentier botanique du collège amiral
pierre-bouvet
aliser la course c'est-à-dire donner
plus d'importance aux espaces verts dans
la cour pour apporter de la sérénité au
collège et aussi de la fierté
d'appartenance pour que les élèves
soient fiers de leur collège qu'ils le
trouvent beau qu'ils en soi fiers qu'ils
aient envie de venir et donc dans cette
revégétalisation on a
on place on met en place un sentier
botanique donc ce sentier bentanique
dans ce sentier botanique on met on met
en place quatre types de plantes on a
les plantes endémique et indigènes de la
Réunion
les plantes médicinales et les plantes
exotiques qui servent d'ornementation un
jardin qui existe depuis maintenant 4
ans mais qui grâce au conseil général
c'est littéralement embellit ces
derniers mois ce projet de
bio et puis il a pris son envol l'année
dernière avec le concours du plus beau
collège fleuri organisé par le Conseil
Général et donc on a été récompensé
puisque le collège a remporté le premier
prix catégorie façade donc c'est ça
vraiment qui a donné l'impulsion l'année
dernière ce concours qui a donné
l'impulsion l'année dernière et
ce qui explique qui est beaucoup
d'élèves impliqués cette année des
élèves ravis donc de planter arroser
surtout de mieux comprendre la
biodiversité de leur île désormais les
plantes n'ont plus aucun secret pour ces
petits collégiens qui ça donne le plus
souvent possible au jardinage mais
surtout à l'élaboration des fiches
présentant chaque plante et leurs
caractéristiques
on entretient les espaces verts on
déracine les mauvaises herbes
sensibilisons les élèves au
développement durable
nous mettons en place des actions pour
les sensibiliser nous avons recouvert
la de sable nous avons mis du gazon
puis nous avons ajouté des plantes comme
derrière nous il y a de la vanille et
tout et de la menthe et tout
sont des plantes qui peut des plantes
médicinales au début il y avait 16
plantes en débits mais maintenant il y a
25 plantes endémiques fédérer les jeunes
autour d'un projet commun mais surtout
les emmener à mieux appréhender les
plantes de La Réunion et leurs bienfaits
la référente à la matière y trouve une
richesse incomparable que la super
passer au 23 élèves de l'atelier jardin
de l'option développement durable
j'estime que les plantes médicinales
sont importantes et c'est une partie de
la culture réunionnaise qu'il faut non
seulement les découvrir mais savoir
comment les utiliser pas faire n'importe
quoi mais les utiliser dans un bon
esprit de préservation de la santé pour
le jardin créole certains élèves ne
connaissent pas ce que c'est que
un pied de manioc des patates des songes
et donc dans le jardin créole et j'ai
voulu recréer cet espace pour permettre
aux génération future de voir tout ce
qui était utilisé anciennement dans les
repas en prévention aussi de citer une
maladie d'obésité un retour en arrière
pour une meilleure alimentation en
montrant l'intérêt des plantes créoles
des
légumineuses etc bravo donc aux quatre
ambassadrices du collège qui ont su
présenter avec beaucoup de passions
leurs projets quand le collège devient
jardin aux membres du jury des sixièmes
rencontrent et co-responsables
l'objectif étant de transformer le
collège en un jardin coloré avec un
sentier botanique riche d'espèces
endémiques indigènes et exotiques
l'apport des plantes médicinales a donné
à ce jardin un caractère patrimonial
dont les enfants et leur encadrants
peuvent être fiers
OK